mais grâce à ma guitare s'appelle dit à
quelle origine dit albanaise albanaise
j'adore et capitale de l'albanie à
tirana et ouais j'en tire à la gent
tirana mais c'est vrai et capitale de
l'albanie à tirana jeu très fort en
capital donnez moi du moins les moyens
d'aller très base
oui bolivie la palce un bulgare hristo
et j'enlève mon auriez vraiment ne rien
sofia chauffeur noir bonnet vissé pas la
base d'une impasse s'enfonce revoir non
alors justement aller en bolivie alors
si on fait des missions hongrie hongrie
budapest un oui la baie rouge et or et
rouge lima australie australie non
au cas où on s'en fout en fait les
pailladins sont soudés capitale des
hammadites à venir on va tous dans des
endroits un petit peu retranché nous
habitons en albanie non non j'habite en
belgique mais qui comprend de la
belgique vous à tuer david jean michel
naud non allez c'est bon merci vous
habite en belgique à bruxelles
vous avez quel âge 19 ans 19 ans elle a
19 ans elle a fait quoi dans la vie
pour la commission européenne il ya
quelques mois j'ai arrêté d'en et wyss
et en haïti support et maintenant j'ai
participé à une télé réalité laquelle
les princes et princesses avant aussi
mais tout le monde fait ça ouais vous
étiez quoi princesse au mur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
prétendante prétendantes sedouki kg
dylan de dylan i'm ready l'adq était
venue seule mais il vous après choisi au
nom mais aussi payé je vais bien merci